and then I met Mourinho what which
was Hardcore mentality but new new thing
like every training we would do
something new we would never repeat an
exercise twice so he would divide the
fields in four four areas so we would go
from every area so everything was new
and he would sit in front of the team
and he would say Direct in our face
listen you will all get a chance if you
would get a second chance no so he was
direct to everybody in that but the the
thing with Mourinho is he makes you
feel so strong that you go out and you
fight for
him and you do whatever it takes to win
so he's like a like a teacher which he I
think his background is also a teacher
so he would he would motivate you on
High level that you would do anything to
go out